and you may begin
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us today
i am incredibly excited to have jeff
harden here with us
to give this webinar for us he is the
raymond e keller professor and chair of
the department of integrative biology
at the university of madison wisconsin
he received his bs in zoology and ba in
german
at michigan state university and then
got his phd in biophysics
at the university of california at
berkeley
he did his postdoc work at duke
university and then
joined the zoology department which is
now the department of integrative
biology
at the university of wisconsin in 1991.
i've personally followed jeff's group as
they've been at the forefront of
developing tools for digital 4d
and 2-photon microscopy in living
embryos
their current research is focusing on
cell cell adhesion
and cell movement in early embryos and
they use
c elegans as a model system
and if you didn't know jeff is a
recognized educator and textbook author
so some of you may have used the world
of the cell
which is an undergraduate cell biology
text
that he is an author of so
thank you very much for joining us jeff
today and
i look forward to watching uh this
webinar thanks
well hello everyone my name is jeff
harden i'm a professor in the department
of integrated biology at the university
of wisconsin-madison
and it's my privilege to be with you
today
what i want to do is to talk a little
bit about some of the work that my lab
does
using the c elegans embryo as a model
system in particular i want to talk
about a movement called dorsal
intercalation
that is similar to movements that many
animal embryos undergo along the way
i'll
tell you a little bit about why i'm
excited about a new andor based
dragonfly system that we're really
looking forward to putting through its
paces
more on that in a few minutes
the fundamental interest of my lab is
morphogenesis
how do you build an embryo
clearly building an embryo is
complicated
we all started off as a one cell zygote
as you see on the upper left
it's really complicated things happen
and then you get something really
complex
at the ends my son christopher about 31
years ago or so
now that embryonic construction project
involves cell movement
involves cell adhesion changes changes
in cell signaling that regulate those
first two
and many of the pathways that model
organism developmental biologists like
me
have been studying for many years turn
out to be misregulated in cancer so in
that sense cancer is the dark side of
development so the things that we learn
here
have general relevance to human disease
and many other things
now one of the bodybuilding movements
that cells in our lambdas engage in
is cell intercalation
it's a key part of the morphogenetic
repertoire in animal embryos and there
are two basic kinds
of that intercalation
first is radial intercalation the blue
and the orange cells here
move between one another starting off as
two rows and then moving
orthogonal to their arrangement to
create a single layer that is
can cover more surface area
the other kind of intercalation is the
one that we'll be talking about and
that's something called convergent
extension
in convergent extension the orientation
of the rearrangement is different so we
have
a group of orange and blue cells again
on the right
but now they undergo mediolateral
changes in position
to make an array of tissue that is
narrower in one dimension
but longer in the other dimension that
movement convergent extension is a very
common one
in tissues that are undergoing explosive
elongation
now it turns out that i've been studying
conversion extension type movements for
a really long time that goes back to my
phd work with a guy named ray keller in
fact i'm now the raymond e keller
professor of integrative biology here at
the university of wisconsin
just to give you a sense for how long
i've been working on this
truth in advertising on the next slide
yes this is me on the right
at ray keller's wedding ray's in the
middle and then
john gerhart was officiating i was the
official wedding photographer
and rey's lab has really done some of
the most seminal work in
understanding convergent extension in
non-epithelial tissues in particular
during
the movements of gastrulation in
amphibian embryos
when i was in rey's lab i worked on sea
urchin gastrulation
a different problem and in secretion
gastrulation
a short squat cylinder the arc enteron
elongates to span
the animal vegetal axis of the embryo
and what my phd work focused on was in
fact showing that conversion extension
occurs during this process and that's
what you see on the right so
that as cells change position
they make a tube longer
but also narrower now as i said ray's
lab has worked
on amphibian embryos and what they've
been able to show over the course of
many many years
is that rearranging non-epithelial cells
deep cells and amphibian embryos undergo
an oriented
change in position via convergent
extension and
uh they were able to use explants and
microscopy
to uh show that
that the cells as they rearrange show
highly
polarized protrusive activity so an
explant that undergoes convergent
extensions on the left and as you see
this movie
play you can see just how dramatically
elongated
this explant gets and that's because uh
its cells
hundreds of thousands of cells are
undergoing convergent extension
and if one looks at cells in an explant
like this fluorescently labeled cells
you can see that they
undergo oriented protrusive activity as
the cells are engaging in
on the right so that kind of convergent
extension is common
in deep or non-epithelial cells
probably the best studied system for
looking at rearrangement of epithelial
cells where most of the action is on the
apical or exterior surface
is the germ band of the drosophila
embryo
so this is a really nice movie from
jen's allen's lab
at rockefeller and as we run this
forward
you will see that cells in the
future epidermis of the fly embryo are
going to undergo
changes in position now as they do this
they form things that are called
multicellular rosettes so let's just run
this forward
and get the idea so as cells are
changing position
they form clusters and those clusters
resolve and the entire tissue elongates
pushing the tissue off the right
edge of the movie in this particular
case
so we have deep cells on the one hand
and frogs we have
epithelial cells driven mostly by the
their apical
surfaces in the case of the germ band
and drosophila but there are other cases
that are sort of in the middle and
that's what we want to talk about today
let me give you a couple of examples and
then we'll talk about
my labs work one is
a a system studied by ed monroe
university of chicago that's the acidity
and notochord primordium in that case as
you see the blue cells on the left
they undergo convergent extension but if
you look at
where the cells are making protrusions
it turns out that they are making
protrusions
neither at their extreme apical surface
or their basal surface but somewhere in
the middle
and the same is true for the the
mammalian neural tube and sutherland at
university of virginia
has done some really nice work actually
filming mouse
uh neural plate morphogenesis and the
same thing is true
in that case these are actually pretty
uh interesting systems
but they're still pretty complicated and
so we've turned to c
elegans as a model organism to try to
look at this kind of intermediate level
uh cell rearrangement event in an
epithelial sheet
and our worms have a number of virtues
that you're probably familiar with many
of these they're simple
got about a thousand cells they're very
reproducible in terms of their
development that
allows for pretty refined analysis of
development
and that was made possible originally by
the transparency of these embryos which
makes them great for microscopy
they also have powerful genetics you can
do reverse genetics using rna immediate
interference rnai
a number of other molecular virtues as
well
now we don't study the adult
hermaphrodites we study the jelly bean
shaped structures that you can see
in this worm those are embryos
in particular we study the embryonic
epidermis which i've
drawn for you here in a cartoon form
there are three basic cell types and we
studied
each of these cell types at various
stages of my lab's
work first the teal cells undergo an
intercalation movement called dorsal
intercalation that's going to be the
focus of our talk
today the pink cells undergo a movement
called ventral enclosure
in which cells migrate to encase the
embryo in skin and then the yellow cells
engage in an actomyosin-mediated
contraction
to squeeze the embryo out into a worm
shape so we want to focus on that first
teal colored group of cells
here's an embryo image using the masking
microscopy and then i've colorized four
cells to show you how they change
position during dorsal intercalation
anterior is on the left posterior on the
right here and you can see that these
four cells become wedge shaped they move
between one another in an alternating
fashion
so that by the end of this movie you can
see that
this group of cells in fact there's 20
of these cells in total
engage in one round of rearrangement to
make a single row
of cells across the dorsal midline
so as far as i know this is the simplest
case of a convergent extension type
movement
and it's really easy to follow with the
nomarski microscopy which we did
initially when we characterized this
process
so here you can see a snapshot of
embryos from a 4d time lapse
the marsky series and i've colorized
some of the cells in in green and blue
here and you can see that
initially the cells are not particularly
polarized but they rapidly polarize they
begin to directionally migrate as you
see in the middle
and then by the end as intercalation is
over you get this characteristic
alternating pattern of intercalated
cells
now we published some work many many
years ago
on dorsal intercalation this was in the
old days when
you couldn't do a lot of sophisticated
digital microscopy but you could do
transmission electron microscopy and so
this is a cell that's been serially
reconstructed from
transmission and electron micrographs
and
the gray here is an epithelial junction
and the red shows the tip of the cell as
it's poking its nose
under the junctions of a contralateral
cell which you can't see which would be
off the left side of this image
so these cells are interesting they're
hybrid cells they're epithelial
and yet they also have to be
protrusively active
to show that they really are epithelial
the next slide shows
a multi-photon movie that i generated
many years ago
in looking at embryos that are
expressing a gfp tag version of a
protein called disks larger dlg1
in worms and the cartoon at the top
shows you
what happens but let me run this movie
forward
and you can see that worms are really
great for imaging with gfp or other
fluorescent
genetically encoded fluorescent tags in
this case what you can see
is that the cells become wedge shaped
and they make a characteristic
ladder-like structure
and by the end of this movie you can see
that some of the cell boundaries
between dorsal cells actually fry away
that's because these cells make
multinucleates incision later in
development
the point here is that we can study
intercalation movements at the level of
single cells
in quite a bit of detail using
genetically encoded markers
right so that was about the the turn of
the millennium
and then a really great student at least
while shannon in my lab
decided to work on intercalation and
here's the system she was working on we
we got it in 2004.
it's a perkin elmer ultraview
spinning disc system with a csu10 scan
head a
hamamatsu orca 2 er and it's now kind of
a franken system i've cobbled together
parts
we control using micromanager
and we bought a solid state launch a
vortran laser launch
and it works still works believe it or
not
but it's pretty primitive by modern
standards nevertheless elise is able to
generate really beautiful movies
uh and and uh data using the system
and here's an example so in this case uh
elise was following a group of cells
which is expressing a green fluorescent
protein tagged
protein fragment that binds f actin
and it's expressed mosaically so you can
see a group of bright cells
on one side of the dorsal array moving
towards the top
of each of the panels and what you can
see as the green asterisks indicate
is that the cells become polarized they
extend protrusions that look very much
like the
lamellapodia of single migrating cells
in tissue culture
and eventually they migrate to the
opposite side
of the dorsal array
so here's a movie that shows this
and it's really striking how
protrusively active the cells are
but also how polarized they are as they
migrate
you can see if you watch carefully at
the very beginning of this movie the
back edge the lateral edges of these
cells
are initially protrusively active but
that protrusion
becomes dampened very rapidly and
protrusion becomes consolidated in the
direction of migration
all right so elise made a z
reconstruction through the thickness of
these cells and that's what you see here
and you can see
that the nucleus is on the left and the
cells
in the reconstruction are migrating
towards the right and you can see
how thin these protrusions are and you
can see
just how highly
oriented they are as they migrate
well uh now it's 2020 and a couple of
current students in my lab yoon zhu and
joel
sear are using a new system that we have
in the lab that we're very excited about
but unfortunately we got stuck in the
the covid transition so we really
haven't been able to put this
system through its paces the way we
would like it's a dragonfly 500 system
and you can see joel is sitting there at
the system
and we're pretty excited about this
first of all it has borealis corrections
so
we get flat beautiful images to the edge
of
the the field of view
we can do fret kinds of imaging with it
we can do a high low turf with it
we also have a mosaic dmd based frap
photo conversion system
we're going to use that for dander
dendra 2 imaging as well as frap
and it has a micropoint ablation laser
as well so we can do celebrations i'll
show you some examples of how we use
micropoint
lasers to do that kind of experiment
later
and one of the things that we're hoping
to do is to do super resolution via
radial fluctuations or surf stream
imaging using the system that's
something that the
andor systems are well equipped to do
all this is integrated with the fusion
software and that has hooks into mrs and
so
we can do deconvolution and a number of
things that are just really going to
float our boat in terms of
imaging during dorsal intercalation so
here's one of the early products of that
this is a deconvolved
series of images using this actin
reporter system that i showed you
previously generated by union in the lab
and you can see just the the beautiful
images here
and this just simply shows that we can
image individual actin filaments
inside of cells as they're undergoing
dorsal intercalation so we're very
excited about this system
right so we've got a system that is
epithelial and yet engages in polarized
protrusive activity what do we know
about it well
for over many years we've been able to
make a few
kind of preliminary observations first
of all if you perturb
junctional molecules it's really hard to
make a dent in this process
so perturbing junctional proteins has
weak effects so what we've done
is to focus on the what we think is the
business end of these cells
and what we know is that these cells
make these oriented protrusions
that look very much like lamellapodia so
what allows for that local
basolateral motility in these epithelial
cells
one obvious place to start is with row
family gtp aces and
you will be familiar with this that rack
cdc 42 and rho regulate
the formation of various kinds of arrays
of actin
based structures particular the rack
family of gtpases regulates things that
look a lot like lamellapodia
but cdc42 is involved in in polarity
and in making more slender phyllopodial
types of protrusions
you'll also probably be familiar with
the fact that
the roe family gtpases are regulated
guanine nucleotide exchange factors or
gifs
gaffs
activate this family of gtp aces
by
stimulating them to exchange a bound gdp
for a gtp to activate these proteins
and gtps activating proteins or gaps
inactivate these by stimulating their
intrinsic enzymatic activity to
hydrolyze their bound gtp
now this is sort of an obvious set of
proteins to go after but it turned out
to be very hard to
study these proteins at this stage of
development and that's because
real family gtpases are used throughout
development
so perturbing them early in a
simple-minded way
leads to a messed a messy embryo
so we needed a way to perform inducible
tissue specific
perturbation of roe family gtp aces i
don't want to go through the details
except to say that we collaborate with
dave reiner
at
the university of texas a
m health sciences university i should
say in houston
and dave's technology
involved an inducible system
that makes use of the
mrna surveillance system the nonsense
mediated decay surveillance system in
worms called the smug system and i don't
want to
say too much about it except to say that
it works in the following way
at the permissive temperature lower
temperatures this this smug system the
surveillance system
prevents persistence of engineered mrnas
made from transgenes
so at the permissive temperature
these mrnas get
turned over and destroyed that's kind of
steady state but if you elevate
to the restrictive temperature the smug
system becomes inactivated
and so now these trans genes can persist
so if you have a dominant negative or
constitutively activated row family
gtpa's construct
now this will be expressed and moreover
we use the tissue-specific promoter to
drive the smug system so that it's only
active in a group of cells and then
by temperature shifting you can allow
these
molecules to persist at the time that
you want
very powerful system and elise while
shannon in the lab used it
to show that satan rack and mic 2 which
is the
worm member of the row g family of rack
related proteins are both involved in
dorsal intercalation
so that's what you see here so across
the top is a controlled embryo that
undergoes normal intercalation you've
seen images like that already
in the the middle section of this
figure elise has expressed using the
smug system a constitutively active form
of rack
and this leads to what we call
ipsilateral co-migration in other words
two cells migrating together instead of
in this alternating pattern
and then expression of a dominant
negative
rack set to dominant negative construct
on the bottom
leads to what we call medial delay or
contralateral fighting cells seem to
stall at the midline and jiggle but they
can't really
intercalate successfully so what this
shows then
is that rac family proteins are required
for normal intercalation
so elise was able to do confocal imaging
as well and so that's what you see here
so
uh the a set 10 dominant negative
is expressed along the top and
you can see that the cells have trouble
making protrusions they can make
very thin protrusions but the
lamellopodial types of protrusions that
one normally sees during intercalation
are blocked by this loss of function and
the same is
true in mic 2 mutants and the two
synergize with one another as well
so rack and row g are required for
dorsal intercalation and
that was a good starting point so then
elise moved outward to look at
possible regulators and one of the
proteins
that she landed on after a genome-wide
screen of rack family guests
was the protein trio which in worms is
called on 73.
trio family guests have two guf domains
they have a row specific guef
a gef 2 domain and they have a rack
specific gaf which is also specific for
row g gef 1 domain
there are mutants available that
abrogate the function
of either the gef1 or the gef2 domain
and that's what
elise used to get advantage he showed
that a
gef 2 mutant is normal for intercalation
but that guef1 mutants have defects in
intercalation that look like the loss of
function
phenotypes that i showed you on the
previous slide
so loss of 73's rack f activity leads to
the same kinds of blunted protrusions
that you've already seen
police also showed that x73 gfp is
expressed at the right time
in intercalating tissues song 73
seems to be activating said 10 rack and
mic
2 rho g
we then capitalized on an observation
that john gorika's group at uc berkeley
had made
and that is that they had identified a
genetic interactor with like 73 trio and
that's something called
caramel caramel stands for capping
protein
arp2 3 and myosin 1 linker it's quite a
mouthful that's why i'll just say
caramel
the rest of the way and these are a
family of proteins that are highly
conserved
in eukaryotes in metazoans
so the human caramel one is on the top
human caramel two
on the bottom the single caramel homolog
called caramel one in worms is in the
middle you can see that the
n-terminus and the leucine-rich regions
and other features
are highly conserved
john's group and then later john
cooper's group at washington university
in st louis and tissue culture cell
showed the carmel
and trio can co-immunoprecipitate
and john's group showed that carmel one
loss of function suppresses
loss of function of unk73 in neurons so
somehow carmel one and one 73 are
antagonizing one another
not entirely clear more on that in a
minute
carmel proteins are interesting so as
the name implies they're multifunctional
proteins they're probably scaffolding
proteins but one of the things that they
do
is that they are capable of binding
capping protein and you may remember
from some cell biology course somewhere
along the way
the capping proteins bind the barbed or
the plus ends of actin filaments
stabilizing them
against subunit loss but also again
subunit addition
so in particular capping proteins
stabilize the tips
of networks of actin that polymerize
via arp2 iii mediated branching that's
the blue complex of proteins that forms
that y-shaped structure on the right
in this slide
so that's interesting so somehow
presumably then
carmels are affecting actin
polymerization kinetics or dynamics
elise walk shannon looked at carmel one
mutants
and in combination with 73 trio mutants
during dorsal intercalation she
quantified protrusive activity and the
polarity protrusions that's what you see
in these rose plots here in this diagram
so wild-type cells show highly polarized
protrusions
mostly pointing straight across the
dorsal array
to the contralateral side of the embryo
that's what you see on the right
but in carmel one loss of function
mutants elise showed that
protrusions form all the way around the
periphery now there is still some bias
and the cells can migrate but they have
more difficulty doing so
and what elise showed was that
introducing a non-73
gef-1 mutant into the caramel one mutant
background
partially rescues or offsets those
polarity defects that's what you see
on the right so actual pictures are on
the next slide you can see these here
caramel one mutant is across the top and
then a double mutant with on 73 and
caramel one
across the bottom so you look at the top
the yellow arrows point
to actin extensions that are in
inappropriate locations so they are
being extended on the
basal or back sides of these cells so
loss of caramel one
leads to excess small protrusions all
the way around the periphery of these
cells
introducing a trio mutation on 73 gif
one mutant
mutation in this background then rescues
these effects so that's what you see
across the bottom you can see that
protrusive activity looks pretty normal
in the double mutant
so somehow trio and caramel act
antagonistically during intercalation
we were really keen to know whether
caramel one was
asymmetrically accumulated in cells
because that might be a mechanism by
which caramel one could act during this
process
so joel sear in the lab made a crisper
based
amnion green knock in for caramel one
and anna hexted image that
in the brief movie on the next slide
this movie is not particularly
interesting i must say what it shows is
the caramel one is present in dorsal
cells
but it seems to be ubiquitous and now
we're analyzing this in higher
detail one of the things that got cut
short by covet 19
was our ability to use our new dragonfly
system to image caramel 1 and neon green
at high resolution
but there's no obvious smoking gun here
so the question then is how might carmel
1 be working
well it's been known for a long time as
i mentioned previously the capping
protein
regulates arp2 3 networks one
possibility here
as exemplified by this nice diagram from
an old paper by dorothy schaefer
is that capping protein might
stimulate further arborization of arp2 3
dependent networks
so on the right side of this image is an
an
early lamellapodium or phylopodium as
it's beginning to grow
in that case there is a lower titer of
capping protein
the idea here then is that filaments can
grow
and this can lead to long filaments in
immature
r23 dependent networks
but as these networks become
progressively stabilized and capped
that's the
red hexagons in the middle in this
diagram
the idea then is that as more and more
filaments become capped the only place
for polymerization of actin to
to occur is via the production of new
side branches so in other words
when capping protein is is acting
this presumably then um
promotes the bushiness or arborization
of these rp3 networks
so if caramel is inhibiting capping
protein normally
then presumably there's some sort of
steady state capping protein level in
these cells and that gives you a normal
kind of network that leads to the normal
kind of productive activity
that one sees but now imagine that we
remove
caramel through caramel mutation in the
case of worms
and in this case then
the prediction would be that now we lose
this antagonism of capping protein
and this somehow leads to excess
dendritic network so we get excess
bushiness of the arp2 3 network
now a prediction here is that if you
overexpress capping protein you'll get
excess networks as well so that should
phenocopy karma 1 mutants
so we're going to test that when we can
get back in the lab
i have to say that these simple kinds of
predictions might not hold true bruce
good's lab in collaboration with the
cooper lab
has shown that there's a really
complicated cyclical
interaction of multiple proteins
including twinfillin
a protein called v1
and caramel proteins that probably is
somehow cyclically involved in
sequestration
and affecting the on off rate of capping
protein at the barbed or plus ends of
actin filaments
and there are some specific predictions
of the kinds of models that bruce goods
lab has constructed
they were interested in testing in vivo
all right so we we looked at guanine
nucleotide exchange factors guess
regulating row family gtp aces and we've
looked at some genetic interactions
there as i've just talked to you about
but what about the flip side what about
gaps well
candidate gap we were really interested
in looking at was one we had already
studied in the context of cat hair
independent cell adhesion
and that's called sr gap 1. so gap 1 is
a single worm family member of a family
proteins that are conserved all the way
up to humans
called slit robo or sr gaps
these have an f bar domain at their
n-terminus that allows them to interact
or possibly
shape membranes they have a gap domain
and the the worm sr gap it turns out
is specific for said 10 rack and mic
2 row g as well as cdc 42
and then they have adapter motifs at
least the vertebrate ones do
at their c terminus
so we identified this in a screen
looking for regulators of cad hair
independent adhesion but this
protein has many interesting properties
well they they get their name because
they physically associate with the slit
robo complex these are growth cone
guidance proteins
and so they're important for neuronal
migration
in humans they lead to a form of mental
retardation at least mutations in sr gap
3 do
and they're involved in production of
membrane protrusions required for
cell migration we showed the same is
true during morphogenetic events and c
elegans embryos
they also bind actin regulators via
their c terminus
so uh bethany lucas when she was in the
lab and then more recently joel sears
worked on
sr gap 1. and sr gap 1 mutants have
defects and intercalation so across the
top you see a wild type embryo
undergoing intercalation on the left the
blue and purple show that the cells are
intercalating as you've seen before
in an sr gap one strong loss of function
mutant in the middle
you can see that we get the ipsilateral
co-migration phenotype so the two blue
cells and two purple cells migrate
together
and joel has shown that mutations
in the slit homolog slit 1 give a
similar phenotype
sr gap 1 gfp is present
in the dorsal hypodermis during
intercalation and
so all of that suggested to us that an
obvious hypothesis and that is that sr
gap 1 is acting as a gap
to down regulate rack dependent motility
during intercalation
so joel used crispr to make a gap dead
mutant of sr gap 1 and to our surprise
it had no effect on intercalation
so we had thought the model on the left
was true that unk-73 activates said 10
rack
and sr gap 1 inactivates set 10 rack
but when joel made the gap dead mutant
he saw
very very minor defects in intercalation
compared to strong loss of function
mutants
moreover joel was not able to show a
genetic interaction between
unk73 and the gap dead sr gap 1
mutant so all of this suggests that in
fact sr gap one is probably not acting
as a gap during this process that's
interesting in a way
so what might it be doing well we think
it might be modulating membrane
curvature so here's an em neon green
knock in for sr gap
1 the joel made and you can see that it
is dynamically deployed at the
edges of cells during dorsal
intercalation and
we're analyzing the accumulation here
but it sure looks like
as cells intercalate that sr gap one
accumulates in bright spots
at sites where cells are going to
undergo neighbor exchange
here's one of the few images joel was
able to generate on the dragonfly before
the covet 19 lockdown
and so this is the deconvolved snapshot
of sr gap on em neon green and you can
see that
it it shows up at the cell periphery
and in fact if you look carefully it's
kind of hard to see perhaps
sr gap one seems to show up at the tips
of cells as they're migrating
contralaterally so one of the
possibilities here
that we favor is that sr gap one is
somehow modulating membrane curvature
which is facilitating neighbor exchange
during dorsal intercalation
all right so we've looked at the
apparatus of intercalation now let's
consider briefly what might
polarize protrusions
and as i told you initially cells make
protrusions all the way around the
periphery
as you see on the left but as
intercalation really gets going
protrusions become highly consolidated
towards the leading edge
and we've looked at the machinery now
what kinds of signals might lead to
polarization of this machinery
well one of the obvious candidates was
cdc42
and so elise when she was in the lab
looked at cdc42 function
and what she found using this smug
system and and other genetic
tricks to perturb cdc42 function
was that loss of function for cdc42
leads to very similar defects to those
that you've already seen
in particular ipsilateral co-migration
and this
medial fighting so across the middle you
see an example
of the the co-migration phenotype and
then on the bottom
cells are have trouble initiating
migration eventually
they do migrate and it leads to
ipsilateral defects
so all of this implicated cdc42 perhaps
in polarizing protrusions which is why
you get the
co-migration defects maybe the the gun
is being aimed
inappropriately well cdc42 is known to
interact with
a protein complex originally discovered
in worms called the par complex
and if you perturb par complex
components you get very similar
phenotypes
so you get defects that look like cdc 42
dependent defects
by perturbing par 3 that's across the
middle or par
6 across the bottom
so that led us to look to see whether
there are
changes in cdc 42 dependent activity at
the onset of intercalation and so we
used a
cdc42 biosensor originally made by
craig comfort who was in john white's
lab
and then this was worked on
by elise walk shannon in my lab so here
here's a movie
showing that cdc 42 is is active during
intercalation this is a movie from a
former postdoc roninzital bar
and if you quantify the amount of signal
here
that's what you see across the bottom in
normal embryos
cdc4i cdc42 activity is elevated
as cells begin to migrate
so that led elise to consider what might
be upstream that leads to cdc42
activation she did a genome-wide
candidate screen and she honed in on a
receptor
called vab1 vab1 is the
single f receptor in c elegans
so f receptors have an extracellular
ligand binding domain they bind efferent
ligands and then they have a kinase
domain intracellularly
and elise was able to look at
vab 1 f receptor mutants particular
mutants that
abrogate various functions of vab1 the
bottom line is that loss of ab1 function
leads a very similar co-migration
phenotype to what i've already showed
you
so elise then used vab1 mutants and the
cdc42 biosensor to look at cdc 42
activity and what she found was that
she got reduction of function of cdc 42
activity
in fab1 mutants
so in a way that's not clear vab 1 acts
as a receptor that
locally activates cdc42 at least that's
the model we're working with
and we're very interested in trying to
determine what ligands might be
activating vab
1 leading to localized cdc 42 activity
leading
to polarized protrusions during
intercalation
right now if you know anything about
this literature you may have been asking
through much of what i've just been
talking about well why didn't they look
at the planar cell polarity pathway
the pcp pathway is well known to
influence
intercalation movements of deep cells in
amphibian embryos for example
that's shown here on this slide from a
review article by
cecilia moen's lab and john wallingford
and others have shown
that the the pcp family proteins
vangle ii or van gogh
as well as the protein
scaffolding molecule prickle are
involved in intercalation
and in intercalating deep cells the idea
is that localized activity
of vangual and prickle
somehow stabilize mediolateral
protrusions that allow cells to
intercalate so you have an array on the
left
that's going to intercalate into a
single row
on the right problem is that in worms
there just really hasn't been
great evidence that there's a true
full-on pcp pathway worms seem to be
derived in this sense
have lost core components of the pcp
pathway we
and many other labs have looked at this
over a period of years
however some components are conserved
including
the vangual homolog which is called vang
one
and antonio colovita's lab showed that
vang 1
is required for what appears to be a
convergent like extension movement of
ventral neuroblasts
in the worm embryo this is work that was
published
in collaboration with chiron bowels lab
and
published in developmental cell several
years ago
that's shown here so pavak shah who was
the first author did really beautiful
imaging here
and that's what you see on the top and
what you can see is that this group of
neuroblasts seems to undergo a
convergent extension-like movement
and what this paper shows is that vang
1 and non-muscle myosin called nmy2
as well as the
roundabout a roboreceptor sax3 are
somehow involved
in probably locally
in allowing cells to undergo neighbor
exchange during
a ventral neuroblastomorphogenesis
so we decided well okay well we'll look
at prickle one and vang one and all i
can tell you is that they're probably
involved but we don't know how
so joel sear looked at prickle one and
that's what you see here this is a
prickle one mutant
and you can see the one of the yellow
cells in this movie
actually fails to intercalate completely
gets pushed off the bottom
of the movie
and prickle one actually has a highly
penetrant dorsal intercalation defect
vang one mutants also give defects and
this is worked by yu yin zhu in the lab
and you can see here it's the same thing
we
get contralateral fighting
and medial delay and we also get
ipsilateral co-migration so
intercalation defects that you've seen
before
units gone on to show that vang one is
expressed at high levels in the dorsal
epidermis all this is promising but
that's all i can tell you right now
right the last thing i want to talk
about actually capitalizes
on an andor product the micropoint which
we actually
had one of the original prototypes of
this device many many years ago
which was originally built by bob nowak
and a former graduate student
ryan king used the micropoint laser
to look at the cellular requirements for
dorsal intercalation
this is irrespective of any molecular
pathways we might identify and
what we hope to do through these
experiments is establish a set of
cellular ground rules
that could narrow the search for
potential or molecular candidates
and i have to say these are mind-blowing
but puzzling experiments
so ryan capitalized on the fact that
worms have very stereotype development
and so you can see here what ryan is
doing
based on the schematic on the left is
ablating various
groups of cells using a micropoint laser
so wild type number is across the top it
undergoes intercalation and some cells
have been colorized in blue so you can
see them easily
you've seen that pattern before
asked well what happens if you get rid
of the cells underneath the dorsal
epidermal cell so the cells in red or
yellow for example that make muscle
or make the intestine their endodermal
cells well ryan did a number of heroic
ablation experiments so if we got rid of
the
intestinal tissue or
group of muscle cells derived from a
cell called ms that's in the middle
you can see that intercalation still
occurs
and if you got rid of every single
muscle cell precursor in the embryo
the same thing intercalation
nevertheless occurs
so non-epidermal cells don't seem to be
particularly important for influencing
what the dorsal cells
are doing that means that dorsal
intercalation is mainly controlled
locally within the epidermis
so ryan did other ablations of epidermal
cells
here's one the anterior cells colored in
pink are derived from a cell in the
early embryo called a b
at the two cell stage and a later cell
called c
gives rise to posterior dorsal cells
colored in blue
so ryan did an a b ablation so the only
cells that
are left are the cells derived
from c in the dorsal hypodermis and he
imaged that
using confocal microscopy in a strain
that's expressing a gfp tag junctional
marker
that's what you see on the top so you
can see that at the end of this movie
there's a group of cells that sure look
like they've undergone intercalation
these would be posterior dorsal cells in
the absence of other
epidermal cells and
just to show you here's a movie along
the bottom showing you
an experiment like this you can see that
the cells are protrusively active boy
they sure seem to be able to intercalate
and they
undergo a movement of their nuclei
that's characteristic of these cells
conclusion from this kind of an
experiment is that intercalation is
controlled locally along the anterior
posterior axis
and doesn't need the underlying cells
and so whatever kinds of molecular cues
we're going to consider they have to be
locally deployed and
i think we're excited to see where
some of our current sets of experiments
that i've told you about today
are going to lead in that regard
right so it's time to summarize
i hope i've convinced you that dorsal
intercalation is a
novel great system for studying this
kind of hybrid
epithelial cell rearrangement
and that it's carried out by rack and
rho g
mediated actin polymerization
it's also regulated by a novel trio
caramel cassette we're really
working hard to understand how caramel
might be influencing
actin dynamics in that regard
sr gap 1 regulates polarization of
dorsal cells and
and does appear to regulate
perhaps membrane curvature during
intercalation
i've also shown you that a cdc 42 par
complex pathway regulates polarization
of dorsal cells and
f signaling is probably upstream of this
polarization
and then intriguingly uh at least i hope
i've convinced you that it's intriguing
um
there are probably other highly
localized polarity cues in play
we're really looking forward to
deploying our new andor based dragonfly
system
to study some of this by using
multimodal imaging and experimental
perturbation
in an integrated imaging package
well thanks for listening i want to
acknowledge
people who did this work i've already
tried to talk about them along the way
but i want to particularly acknowledge
joel syrian jew in the lab right now
anna hechstadt is picking up on the
carmel
project and i want to acknowledge
lab alums at least while shannon did a
lot of really fine work on roe family
gdp aces
bethany and ronan did some work on sr
gap one
ryan king did the ablations that i
mentioned and then paul high now
williams massan got this whole dorsal
intercalation story started many many
years ago in the lab
i want to thank my funding sources a
generous grant from the wisconsin alumni
research foundation
which funds my raymond e keller
professorship
and the national institutes of health
and our collaborator dave reiner
thanks very much
thanks jeff that was a great talk as
someone who
has um done a little bit of polarity
work and
uh cell polarity and tissue polarity in
the past that was super interesting
and the model is so beautiful i'm
impressed by how much you can see with
those cells
um so we have a a few questions
um and and coming from this tissue
polarity
background of mine um can you talk a
little bit more
about um you were mentioning that worms
don't have a full planar uh cell
polarity pathway can you tell us more
about that
and what's known so far yeah i'm happy
to
so first of all thanks for having me
meredith and um
this is uh my first uh all on virtual
speaking engagement so this is a new
experience for me
um so uh the main evidence that there's
no full pcp
pathway in worms comes from loss of
function experiments so if you take away
certain things that are absolutely
essential in
fruit flies and in vertebrates
that should be involved in helping cells
to polarize themselves
you often get surprisingly mild
phenotypes for most of them
it seems that one of the things that
worms have done is to substitute
highly asymmetric and stereotype cell
divisions for some of the things that
other organisms use pcp for so the main
thing you use it for is to
so that cells sort of know where they
are in space but if you're hardwired
based
on your genealogy then you don't need
that mechanism and that's the argument
that most
people in the field make i think but
having said that
you know i think there is some evidence
that at least some of the components
are doing something similar to what they
do in in other organisms just the
the full pathway that involves frizzles
and
flamingo and all these other components
that one might be familiar with from
other systems
they just don't do very much in worms
when you take them away so that's that's
the main evidence
um having said that it's a little bit
hard because if you
some of these things if you remove their
function you just get a
totally messed up embryo so kind of the
experiment's over
so it's not all the experiments have
been done in a way that provides the
kind of temporal specificity of
of loss of function that you would like
okay thanks for that um keeping with
the polarity theme you were speaking
about how cdc 42
promotes phylopodia but we also know
that it's
it's intertwined in establishing
cell polarity or in involved in cell
polarity events
so what do you think's going on here
with those two functions
and and how it's uh what role it's
playing in this specific
uh process yeah that's a good question
i'm not sure we have a complete answer
to that i'll tell you a little bit of
what we know so
um cdc42 associates with the par
um atypical protein kinase c apkc
complex
and that's where it's involved in
polarity and that can be
front to back polarity of a single cell
it can be
apico basal polarity it can be all kinds
of epithelial kinds of polarity or
neuronal polarity but then cdc42 it's
also clear it plays roles in
stimulating the formation of particular
kinds of active networks is probably
independent of that
polarity function it's hard to do clean
experiments there sometimes so let me
tell you what we've done
to try to address this i showed some
data on the par complex and the talk
so we do believe it's probably doing
something
to help polarize cells it's not clear
exactly what it's doing though i will
say like the experiments that we've done
so far
fall short of kind of nailing exactly
how it might be working with the par
complex
what we know in terms of the actin piece
is that
if you make double mutants for loss of
cdc42 function
and loss of let's say rack function or
rho g
function you get synergistic effects on
protrusion production not just the
orientation of the protrusions but
whether you make them at all
and so we think we think there probably
is a function there in terms of
stimulating
part of the actin network that's that's
being produced as these cells are
migrating
and in particular if you get rid of
cdc42 then the little spiky
protrusions that tend to coalesce or
transform into more lamellopodial types
of protrusions those are the things
that are missing in cdc 42 laws
so probably cdc42 is doing both things
during this process
it's kind of hard to do super clean
experiments to tease that apart
mm-hmm okay um
so it was also really interesting to
hear you talk about
vab one and its role here as well
you gave us a little bit of a tease um
uh saying that you were looking into
what the ligand
might be and um in this pathway
uh can you tell us a little bit more
about that or which ones you're going to
test and go after
yeah so the the classical ligands for f
receptors are called
ephrins and worms have several efferents
um another one of the vad mutants called
vab2 is one of the afferents there's
another one called efn4
efferent iv and um
uh neither of those gives the same
strong phenotypes that loss of vab one
does so normally
and and then um taking both of those out
together
also doesn't do that so that's
if there's some other perhaps
non-canonical ligand so so we looked at
something
which david greenstein's lab at
university of minnesota has looked at in
a completely different context
it's a protein called vpr1 and they
looked at that
that they showed during oenessus oddly
that vab1 the f receptor and this other
thing
are probably a receptor ligand pair and
they're somehow regulating
ovulation and so i don't think that has
anything to do with our
situation but i will tell you that if
you get rid of vpr1
you mess up dorsal intercalation for
sure but boy the embryos are just
they look horrible so we have to find
cleaner
temporal specific ways to remove the
function of dpr1
in a temporal or tissue specific way
than we've done thus far and
it's possible but we just haven't gotten
around to those experiments so
my if i'm going to put money on what we
know so far it's probably that vpr1 is
doing something as a like
and um it's not evident that there's any
sort of spatial localization
to bpr1 distribution at this stage so
um so we're not really sure how the
whole vamp pathway
leads to spatial asymmetries during
intercalation something we really like
to know
cool okay and then we'll finish up with
one last question
and um we have uh
we know that prickle is has been
implicated in
interacting with myosin can you tell us
just a little bit more about that
sure so yeah john wallingford's group in
particular working in xenopus
has done a lot of nice work on
convergent extension and the role of
prickle there
and they actually showed a slide that
really talks about john's lab's work
although the slide was produced by
somebody else
by cecilia mohan's but so what john's
lab has shown
is that well actually ray keller's lab
originally showed that there are these
really interesting highly dynamic
networks
under the cortex involving actin and
myosin
in xenopus cells that are undergoing
convergent extension
and what john's lab has shown is that if
you perturb prickle
you get strong perturbations in this
network
so uh and there's there's other evidence
that
that
perhaps myosin physically associates
with prickle which is probably acting
like a
some sort of adapter comp or nucleating
a complex of proteins it's acting as an
adapter protein
so we've looked at non-muscle myosin in
worms it's actually
really hard because the two non-muscle
myosins that one has to look at are also
required for cytokinesis in the early
embryo
so you have to get around the early
requirement during the cleavage stages
and so elise did some preliminary
experiments that are provocative but i
feel like we need to do some better
experiments so what she did was
she made a a mutant for
non-muscle myosin 1 nmy1
and that protein is functionally
redundant with another non-muscle myosin
called nmy2
so she had a mutant for nmy1 and then
she made a double mutant that contained
that mutation so it couldn't make that
protein and then
it carried a second mutation in the nmy2
gene which is temperature sensitive
and then she did temperature shifts at
around the time of intercalation
and you definitely get failure to
complete intercalation in fact the back
ends of the cells
uh look the cells look sort of
triangular in shape so the
the back ends never kind of squeeze
it looks as if the cells are not getting
squeezed into a more sort of rectangular
shape and so
um i don't know if prickle relates to
that we
will have to do a lot more experiments
we've looked at nmy2
gfp in a prickle loss of function
background nothing obvious leaps out at
us
but that's also not a very definitive
statement i just made so yeah
so we want to look at that when we can
get back in the lab
lots of things to do when you get back
into the lab
um so i think we're gonna wrap up
but is there anything else that you'd
like to say to the audience jeff
no except uh thanks so much for
listening uh it's been a privilege to be
here and
i you know this is an andor event but i
have to say i am really excited about
using that dragonfly that's one of the
first things we're really going to hit
hard winged
working around well i'm glad everyone is
excited for it i think we're all missing
our microscopes right now
um i know i'm missing hearing about all
the fun images
uh coming off of them uh thank you again
so much
uh for doing this with us and for giving
a great talk
i it was really nice to see lots of
pretty movies in there
so thank you again and thank you to
everyone who's joined us today
and thank you to the lab roots crew for
helping us out
um i hope everyone has a a great day and
a great week take care thank you